are all the ghosts in ghostbusters evil
how does the nypd feel about the
ghostbusting going on in their city does
rey have a ghost fetish ghostbusters
looks a lot different as an adult than
it did as a kid when you watch
ghostbusters as a kid there's a good
chance you get the sense that dr peter
bankman is the guy in the movie would
like you to aspire to be
back off man
i'm a scientist after all he still gets
to be a successful business founder like
his buddies rey and egon but he also
gets the crack jokes all the time and
he's the one who gets the girl by the
end of the movie bankman is very clearly
put in position to be the cool
ghostbuster but when you watch the film
as an adult particularly in the 21st
century it also becomes clear that he's
kind of a creep when we first meet peter
venkman he's conducting an experiment on
a pair of volunteer college students one
of whom is an attractive young woman he
delights in torturing the other male
subject of the experiment while
lavishing the woman with praise and even
flat out lying to her in an effort to
possibly hook up with her later when he
meets dana it's clear that she sees
through him a bit more but he's still
not the most sincere guy in the world
with her of all the ghostbusters bankman
is the one most likely to lie his way
into bed with a woman and it's not
always easy to overlook
much of the main plot of ghostbusters
involves the team finding financial
success as alternative exterminators
they have a station they have equipment
they have a rapid response vehicle and
they go out in jumpsuits and trap ghosts
much like a pest control expert would
set up traps to get rats out of your
attic you know it's just occurred to me
we really haven't had a completely
successful test of this equipment i
blame myself so do i
before that though the ghostbusters were
scientists who made a major breakthrough
in their field they confirmed not just
that ghosts were real but that they
could be contained we see montages of
the ghostbusters success as it echoes
around the world and makes him into
celebrities but what the movie never
shows us is the rest of the scientific
community responding to their
breakthrough in an active way are they
sharing their tech with other scientists
are other labs trying to develop their
own ghost equipment since they're making
so much money you might think they'd
franchise but we never see that come to
fruition either for such massive
overnight successes you'd think they'd
have a little more attention from other
scientists
one of the most infamous scenes in
ghostbusters is a brief moment when
rey's stance as a dream in the dream he
is lying in an ornate bed with a
beautiful ghostly presence hovering over
him and his pants unzip and ray's eyes
crossed implying that the ghost is
servicing his proton pack
you're not sleeping with it are you
right
[Music]
what's interesting about this stream and
the fact that the film bothered to show
it to us is that apart from this moment
ghostbusters never really attempts to
highlight any good-natured or helpful
ghosts at best most of the ghosts in the
film are cast as pests at worst they're
outright evil spirits yet here rey is
imagining his dream woman as a gorgeous
ghostly being who wants to give him
pleasure with this in mind and his
enthusiasm for his work we're forced to
ask is rey's particular kink ghosts
that's great actual physical contact can
you move
ray ray come in please i feel so funky
perhaps the most memorable visual in all
of ghostbusters comes near the end of
the film when gozer demands that the
team choose the form of the destroyer
that's coming to ravage the city they
try to empty their minds but ray can't
help but thought from popping into his
head and that's when a massive
marshmallow mascot shows up to stomp
through new york city it's the stay puft
marshmallow man
the stay puft marshmallow man doesn't
have time to do a whole lot of damage
before the ghostbusters managed to
essentially roast him but he does crash
through a good portion of manhattan and
the resulting marshmallow group covers
quite a bit at fifth avenue by the time
it's all over the whole city and by
extension the whole country saw what
happened so what did the owners of stay
puft do in response to this do they put
out a statement clarifying that they had
no involvement in their mascot's hijinks
when you're an adult who's very used to
brands making various plays for
attention it becomes a question worth
asking
ghostbusters doesn't spend all that much
time breaking down how the system of
ghost capture and control actually works
but we do get a glimpse into what
happens to the spirits after the boys
bust them as rey explains to winston
they put the trapped ghost into their
specially designed storage facility
which is basically some kind of
electronic grid that stores a ghost in a
secure way what the film doesn't ever
explore is what if anything the ghosts
actually think or feel about their new
home the ghosts we see over the course
of the film at least some of the time
appear to be semi-sentient creatures and
many of them appear to be mischievous
but not outright evil is it for lack of
a better word humane to keep them all
trapped in there can they feel it
some of the ghosts and ghostbusters seem
like genuinely terrifying beings that no
one would want to be around while others
seem a bit more quirky and less prone to
actually inflicting harm on anyone still
to the ghostbusters they all seem to
just be another form of past like
roaches or silverfish their job isn't to
reason with a ghost or to judge them or
even to separate the bad ones from the
relatively good they just seem to be
trapping them and storing them in their
special grid from a kid's point of view
this probably makes sense but watching
the film as an adult you may get the
overwhelming sense that this probably
isn't fair to some of those ghosts the
ones that were just doing a little quiet
haunting and basically minding their own
business
is there any kind of screening system
that the ghostbusters employ or are they
just locking all those ghosts up
together perhaps one day egon spengler
went on to teach a class on the epics of
busting
there's not a lot of time in
ghostbusters to really get into the
logistics of what the team does or the
broader impact it has on new york city
and the film doesn't really need to shed
more light on it it's not what the film
is for and when you're a kid you don't
necessarily think about it when you
watch the film as an adult though
there's a good chance your brain will
start to turn to the various economic
social and logistical challenges
presented by what is basically a brand
new service the ghostbusters are in many
ways set up like exterminators but most
exterminators don't have a car equipped
with lights and sirens that allows them
to speed through the streets with
impunity how do the nypd and the fdny
feel about these guys do they ever get a
heads up when they're out on the job do
they ever work together if not it feels
like maybe the ghostbusters should have
given them a little more warning
the major supernatural antagonist in
ghostbusters is gozer a powerful entity
that seeks to re-enter the earthly plane
via dana's apartment building which
basically acts as a tuning fork for
psychic energy and will open a portal
for the creature before that can happen
though gozer has to possess two people
to become its key master and gatekeeper
it finds these people and neighbors dana
barrett and louis tully and ultimately
manages to possess both of them with its
servant zul and vince clortho
respectively when the gatekeeper and the
keymaster finally meet in dana's ruined
apartment they share a passionate kiss
and then walk up a supernatural
staircase to the roof of the building
the next time we see them the adults in
the room might notice that it certainly
appears from lewis's expression and
posture that the two just had a rather
hasty erotic encounter it's not clear
from the end of the film how much either
person remembers or might later remember
about their encounter so they did get
intimate are these awkward neighbors
going to uncover some really weird
memories later
while gozer is the main antagonist of
the film ghostbusters also has another
major bad guy in the form of
environmental protection agency
inspector walter peck the idea that a
government agency wants to have a look
at what these guys have cooking at their
brand new possibly dangerous business
isn't anything strange but when peck
actually tries to do his job it becomes
clear that he's very very bad at it and
we're talking bad on the most basic
level first peck asks to see the
ghostbusters ghost storage facility
thank men won't let him so he goes and
gets a court order which for a guy in
his job actually makes a lot of sense
then he uses that court order to turn
the ghostbusters grit off without any
scientific investigation think of the
things he could learn the regulations he
could write and instead he's just keen
on shutting them down with barely a look
then he goes to the mayor and calls it
all a hoax despite the grid blowing up
many critics have viewed peck as the
film's response to government regulation
as an impediment to small business
owners which would certainly explain
peck's cartoonish incompetence it could
be at least a little more thorough check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]